[Music]
hey everybody I'm Christopher Crosby I
made partner engineer here at Google
cloud so what that means is that I help
our partners in the data and analytics
space such as Hortonworks here either
build move or integrate their products
onto the Google cloud platform and I'm
actually really excited to hear because
before I came to Google and was partner
with Hortonworks I was actually a
Hortonworks customer I was the data
science manager at a large cancer
institution in New York City
and when we were there we had this
really great enterprise data warehouse
the data in it was just pristine
everything that was supposed to join
together and joined together hundreds of
ETL processes running every night we had
workflows it could go through and make
sure that data got corrected when errors
were found however what we found was we
would build these models off that data
we'd have these great AUC curves and
everything but then when we went to
actually put those into production or
put those into an actual workflow they
fell apart on us and that's because the
data that we actually had access to in
real time was very different than that
pristine data warehouse data what we had
in real time that data was unstructured
it was tons of duplicate it was riddled
with errors so what we did is we worked
in Porton works we set up a small Hadoop
environment we could start collecting
all of those various transactional
messages that we're flying around the
hospital during the day and so with that
we can start building our models on top
of those data structures with the with
the goal of hopefully giving us much
more accurate models because it was
based on data that actually represented
what was available so it's been a lot of
fun for me to first be on that customer
side of Hortonworks but now to be
partnered with them and getting to take
a peek a little bit behind the curtain
and see how this product has actually
developed so hopefully with today's
session I can give you some of those
insights too so here's an overview of
what we're going to talk about today so
first of all I just kind of set up where
we are with the Google and Hortonworks
partnership today
I'm not gonna lift the hood a little bit
on Google Cloud storage and how that
integrates with Hadoop and a couple
differentiators you should know about if
you're used to working with other object
stores and Google Cloud Storage then I'm
gonna hand off to Sid one of the
principal engineers at Hortonworks who's
going to give you an overview of hybrid
environments and enterprise security as
well as give you very prescriptive
guidance for how you should be deploying
Hortonworks on google cloud and then
finally john product manager from
Hortonworks has an awesome demo with
cloud break on google cloud so you
definitely want to stick around for that
so as you get started you know where we
are with our partnership horton works in
google cloud accelerates next-gen big
data in the cloud all right so obviously
that's a line that came to me directly
from the marketing folks but what does
this actually mean what this means is
more options for hybrid Hadoop
deployments as well as extending your
enterprise applications into the cloud
so the way this is actually done is the
GCS the Google Cloud Storage connector
for Hadoop is now integrated into the
Hortonworks platform and it's fully
supported Hortonworks data HTTP as well
as Hortonworks dataflow hdf are both
fully compatible with the Google cloud
platform integrated and supported so
what does this actually mean to you as a
customer what features can you expect
well you can definitely expect more
agility and ability to run ephemeral HDB
workloads you should also be expecting
to maintain those same enterprise
applications and extend them into the
cloud so more specifically things like
your metadata management tools you
should be able to take those and extend
that into the cloud you're no longer
have to break your data lineage if
something goes into the cloud same thing
with your security and compliance models
those are going to be consistent now
between on Prem and the cloud so you
don't have to necessarily go through and
redevelop and re audit everything for
security now we're gonna talk about some
of the caveats with that later it's
gonna address that but in general you'll
be able to take a little those same
paradigms and move those to the cloud
and of course all of this is going to be
a hundred percent
source both Google and Hortonworks are
very aligned in terms of making sure
that we are contributing back to the
open source community and so both the
GCS connector as well as Hortonworks are
contribute our can committed to making
this a hundred percent open source so
before we get to the new Hortonworks
model just a level set I do want to talk
briefly about something that's existed
in the cloud for a while and this is the
Google Cloud storage this can be used
alongside HDFS the Hadoop file system to
separate your storage from your compute
you can make this your persistent
storage layer and the advantage to this
is now you can start to scope your jobs
or scope your clusters to the job so
instead of spending a lot of time
building these SPARC configurations to
send to a multi-purpose cluster that's
gonna then go compete for resources
which you can do with things like Cloud
Data proc is if you have a machine
learning heavy job you spin up a compute
heavy cluster send your machine learning
job to that if you have interactive
analysis job so things like you know hi
or you want to have a lot of a bi layer
that can just be a memory heavy cluster
and you send jobs to that and data
product has a lot of features such as
workflow template that will help you
build these and we have customers like
our friends at Spotify Labs who actually
create a framework called spinner that
sits on top of data proc that'll also
help you dynamically side these to size
these jobs but with this Hortonworks
partnership what we were really able to
do now is we can start to mix and match
entire hadoop distributions
along with the the job sizing as well
and so that architecture it's really
powerful if you use it correctly this is
also going to be a big cost savers as
well see the idea here is that now
pointing all to the same source of data
you're HDB users so those folks that's
just spent the last five years learning
and barri and are happy with it or your
data analysts that really like working
in the high
with interface with Ted's and they want
to keep all of that all those enterprise
features they can simply move that to
the cloud
however as you're finding some jobs that
maybe don't require a lot of those
enterprise features you can spin that
like MIT nightly ETL jobs is a good
example of that you can start to spin
those off into short-lived data crop
clusters and save some money also
because all the compute and storage is
decoupled you can have more experimental
clusters things like your maybe your
data engineering your data science team
they want to start experimenting with
spark two three running on kubernetes
they can still be pointing at the same
data sets that all your enterprise HDB
users are using now I think it is worth
taking a quick pause because I talk a
lot about hey just for play or you know
use these good these cloud storage
mechanisms instead of HDFS but I think
it's worth a pause to talk about what's
actually happening because there are
some changes that take place especially
in the security layer as you make these
changes and it's worth understanding you
know what's happening and why so this
you know the GCF connector what that's
doing it's not actually it's kind of a
misnomer but it's not actually pulling
data into HDFS it is at the block level
and over Google's very high-performing
network just directly accessing that
data and so Hadoop assets abstract
notion of a file system of which HDFS is
just one implementation you can also use
GCS s3 a and various other assistants
and this was originally designed by the
folks who were developing the dupe that
was pretty fortuitous the way they did
this is you don't want to like when
you're working big data you want to be
able to have block sizes of like 64 gig
but you don't want that limited just a
one disk on one machine so you have
strapped that away you just deal with
the blocks of data and so that works
great for both HDFS as well as GCS
however what that does mean is a lot of
that metadata information at the file
system level that's not necessarily that
from that storage subsystem and that
doesn't go into the Hadoop layer so
that's important again for
some security considerations meaning you
have things like Apache Ranger it's not
always the easiest idea just the best
idea just to slap that on to GCS storage
because that really in relies on HDFS
permissions and some positive compliance
things but we definitely do want to
learn more about how this connector
works because there's a lot of benefits
to using this storage connector even
though some of the security paradigms
change so for instance as we just talked
about you get that direct data access
this is not just pulling data into HDFS
this is actually pulling blocks of data
over Google's high-performance network
however even with that direct data
access you're still going to get your
HDFS compatibility all your jobs are
going to work the same you just need to
change the prefix of some of your files
from HDFS to GS and you should be off
and running
but with that compatibility you're also
gonna get a lot of cloud
interoperability so you're it makes it
very easy when you just have this
separated persistent storage layer to
move from Hadoop to spark to even other
Google cloud services so it's really a
great gateway for getting into these
some of these more interesting
higher-level Google services like
bigquery so I was working with a
ecommerce company and their pattern is
they start with all of their log data
that's you know sequential output and
they were just run straight and
MapReduce on that then that data they
start to analyze with spark and turn
that into these business data marts so
things like this is mostly for marketing
analytics so it's things like their
campaigns or their per customer views of
the data and then they store that in
Google bigquery and that becomes pretty
much their enterprise data warehouse
where their data analysts can use it to
understand the business better put their
in tableau dashboards and things like
that on top of it and so this is all
possible because of the data
accessibility so when you shut down a
Hadoop cluster
you're gonna lose access to all that
data they're sitting in HDFS it's really
tied to these spinning discs that's not
true with Google Cloud Storage it's
separated so your applications can still
access that data you
your Hadoop cluster isn't running and of
course even though it's accessible is
also highly available it go and this is
done without much of a performance loss
but the really cool thing about both the
accessibility and the availability is
there's really no storage management
overhead on your part so anybody that's
administrating HDFS today knows kind of
the pain points of running checks on
that data upgrading versions doing roll
backs that kind of work is done except
with cloud storage it's done by the
Google site reliability engineering team
it's not something that your team's
gonna have to carry a pager for so it
really helps with that overhead you're
also gonna get quick startup so
typically with HDFS you don't get to
start running jobs until your name node
comes out as a safe mode with Google
Cloud Storage as soon as your workers
come online you can start to access that
data and process that data and a lot of
customers that we're working with over
time has told us that that's cost
savings because Google's is a cloud is
something that bills at the per second
level so if you're talking about minutes
every time a federal cluster comes up
for a specific job over time that's
going to be a significant cost reduction
for that quick startup you're not going
to be paying for the inefficiencies of
startup times and then finally you get
integrated into the Google cloud
security ecosystem and you'll get to
take advantage of all the cloud security
but again I definitely want to point out
this is a great that it gets you in
there
but you want to be aware of the changes
that do occur because that's their
different storage subsystem and you're
gonna have to manage these different
storage subsystems HDFS in Google Cloud
Storage a little bit differently so a
couple quick tips for working with
Google Cloud Storage you definitely want
to be taken advantage of our different
storage classes of GCS so other object
stores that you might be accustomed to
working with they've have separate API
calls where if I put something into an
archive or cold storage I have to call
separate API we store that in for hours
all three of these storage classes are
the same API calls same system if your
jobs will work the same between region
George or Nearline storage it's just a
matter of where you put them
so regional storage that comes in two
flavors multi regional regional and this
is where most of your data is gonna live
this is what you're going to use
interactive hive or spark analysis or
and the rule of thumb here is basically
any batch job that'll occur more than
once a month
now Nearline storage is the next here
down and this is really for batch jobs
that you're going to use for historical
reporting or aggregations rule of thumb
here is you're gonna touch data about
once a month
this is Nearline storage and then
finally code line storage comes into
play so that post-process data stuff you
probably don't think you're gonna use
again but you want to keep it around
just in case or maybe you have
compliance reasons to keep it around
rule of thumb there if you think you're
gonna touch it once a year or less code
line now next tip is don't be afraid to
use GCS as a destination so GCF Google
Cloud storage we provide strong global
consistency for a lot of those
operations that are relevant to Hadoop
we'd have to write reactor metadata a
reactor delete bucket listing object
listening so some other object stores
you may have worked with in order to
they're eventually consistent so to get
around that with a dupe you have to
build some kind of kludgy architectures
where you might have a no sequel
day-to-day so it sits in between the
object store and a dupe that's gonna
keep track of what the files are
actually doing what's available for the
most part that all goes away with GCS
you can just use it as a destination now
there's a couple outlier cases there
such as like a rename store non-atomic
but what our customers have told us that
for the most part it works fine for the
vast majority of use cases to use GCS as
a destination so if you want to get
started with this you can go try it on
pretty much any Apache Hadoop system
that you have all you have to do is drop
a single jar file into the class path
and you can pull that jar right off of
our github repo starting to release 1-9
it's going to work with both the due two
three and two do two and three and then
you just have to configure the
permissions so if you're in Google Cloud
Storage our google cloud itself
definitely take advantage of service
accounts for this that'll give you that
transparent
token exchange but if you're coming from
on-prem or a different cloud go ahead
and you can set those credentials in the
course I filed so with that I'm gonna
hand over to Sid who's gonna talk more
about hybrid environments enterprise
security stress so I'm Siddharth state I
work as an engineer at Hortonworks
I've been associated with a bunch of
hurdle projects I've they is yarn
mm-maybe for about seven years now so
before we getting started I just like to
set some context on hybrid environments
as well as security which will be useful
later on in the talk so first up is the
Hortonworks data plane service what we
so this is the service lets you manage
your on-prem as well as flower clusters
in a single environment it gives you a
view of all of these clusters and also
so the data plane platform itself lets
you run services on top of it and that's
where really where you get the value
some of these services are the data
stewards earlier we need a lifecycle
manager which are already available and
what's coming soon is the data analytics
to do cloud break and it's possible for
additional services to be added to the
same platform the the data plane
platform provides an interface to access
these clusters as well as user
management and role management for the
services so DSS and dlm are two services
which I'll talk about today
DSS lets you manage your data sets
whether they're on Prem or on cloud
storage you can view today's data sets
you can view access patterns it comes
with a it comes with a view which lets
you look at audit information to see who
has accessed the data when the
essentially the access patterns on the
data it also comes with a few profilers
very interesting one over there is the
sensitive data or PII data profiler
which can scan through your datasets
datasets and figure out essentially it
can go in tagged sensitive data at a
column level or at a later set level
which then integrates later on without
lesson Ranger and we'll come to that dlm
serves as dalm is the data lifecycle
manager it provides one well it's
responsible for data and metadata
replication so it lets you replicate it
on between on-premise waters cloud
environments it also serves as your
disaster caused or disaster recovery
solution because it's it's replicating
both the data metadata associated with
hi labels as well as your arranger
ordered policies or any security
policies which you have in Reiter all
right so why it's it's great that we can
run Hadoop clusters if you look at very
simple to know clusters you have storage
and you have computer very often that's
not enough for enterprises it's great
that they can run their jobs but
enterprises require governance and
security in place towards this several
components says Knox which serves as
parameter security especially in cloud
environments you don't necessarily want
to expose all of your endpoints over the
public cloud Knox secures all of these
public endpoints the high meta store of
course has metadata about your tables
and data in general and we'll talk a
little bit more about Ranger or Nautilus
so Ranger gives you for people who
haven't used these products already
Ranger gives you authorization policies
for oil data so this can be at let's say
the database level at a table level in
addition to that what's very important
here is it gives you fine grained access
control so you can potentially go and
say that a certain column is sensitive
data flag that and set up a policy to
say that only certain individuals or
certain organizations have access to
this data if someone else were to try to
access the data the data lines are
getting masked when running a hive query
another piece over here is stack based
policies and we will come to that when
we put all these systems together Atlas
is for posture atlases for governance so
this this keeps
lack of data lineage as well as data
classification so when you when you
generate a new data set you you'll be
able to say where what the source data
sets were where to get to this data that
information is always tracked Atlas also
has its integrated with most parts of
the Ruby code system and it has api's
for integrating with external components
in case you have an external data source
and you're bringing data in from there
it has api is to integrate with that now
putting all of this together let's say
DSA yeah
DSS Ranger and Atlas you could end up
saying the DSS sensitive data profiler
runs to type tag sensitive data on all
of your data sets that then sets up tags
in Atlas or you could manually set of
tags in Atlas and after that you said
our policies and range are saying that
any data with this specific tag is only
accessible to users who are authorized
to use the data and this provides a very
powerful abstraction for the entire
security mechanism securing your data
making sure you have an audit trail
ranger takes care of the audit for all
of your data access so that is just a
set context for the rest of the
presentation so deployment architecture
so the cloud is what we talk about next
so this is a diagram of your typical
on-prem deployment now these are
typically long-running clusters they're
shared by multiple users
resource management is handled by yarn
queues different organizations can end
up sharing the same cluster they'll have
allocations within your queues this
cluster is secure will typically be
secure that you have authentication in
place it's right here a lot Kerberos
will be in place data sits on HDFS
temporary data is called out separately
over here it sits on the same HDFS is
called out separately because we're
gonna write rate on the side I'm further
down there's meta store there's range or
artless Atlas isn't explicitly called
out here but there's Ranger or Atlas in
place for your security in governance
very important here is also that all of
these components this this cluster is
long-running it needs to be reliable
it's all the all the masters are highly
available this is a simplification of
the same diagram which we like to read
upon further down again data and
template are here or the same HDFS they
just called out so that VT nitrate on on
this diagram so it sits as a first step
it's very tempting to kind of say okay I
have an architecture on Prem let me just
take the same thing provision v ends on
the cloud and run the same architecture
on the cloud with data sitting on HDFS
now while the in theory is simple to
reason about its it's not really the
best way forward the main problems here
are one is data sitting on HDFS which
means if you you can't really scale your
cluster that well if you remove while
HDFS data is replicated if you remove
enough nodes you will end up losing data
ultimately you can use persistent lists
and then you'll have to deal with
reattaching this when you scale up or
scale down the cluster so it's not
necessarily the best mechanism to use
when migrating to the cloud all right
moving over to some cloud deployment
models which can be used so you start
thinking a little differently when
moving from one prendre cloud now all of
these deployment architectures serve
different use cases and can be used the
first one here is very simple as a
femoral cluster the pieces in the red
outline are optional components so your
first step is to say I'm gonna move I'm
going to have compute I have temporary
HDFS only for temporary data on the
cluster and main storage goes to GCS
over here and then this system Hadoop
security is optional that you can
instead rely upon cloud security which
includes I am network security rules to
make sure only certain people have
access to the system there is no major
data there's there's no meta data when
you get started you can attach metal
store to it if you want you can add a
stranger to policies at a later point
but you end up redefining the same thing
Oh
and over again it's great for our jobs
moving oil is where we introduce shared
services so this point what we're what
we're doing is we take the metadata and
which we split the cluster date to move
to different entities we have the shared
services cluster which at this point
becomes a long-running system it's
always on all the clusters will be
launched and will attach to this again
in this model you can rely coop security
is optional it's it's very similar to
the previous one the data the main data
sits in GCS the advantage we get over
here is that the metadata is always
available it's easy to discover data you
can attach as many clusters as you want
and all of them will see all of the all
of the metadata and will be able to
access the data wire GCS itself if you
do what authorization you will again
define a new Ranger I raise your own
heartless and you will connect to that
but you will have to redefine your
policies now this is a system which
works really well a use case so this
would be development environments so in
as an example in Hortonworks
this is used extensively where we pre
generated some data sets on GCS the meta
data is sitting in cloud SQL and we
attach the meta store to it and whenever
we need to try out your core do some
testing etc we've spin up a new cluster
do the testing do the experiments tear
it down to save cost so taking this to
the next level and this is where we get
into the enterprise security space we're
going to move Ranger also into this
shared service cluster as well as Atlas
again it's not called out over here but
range or not let's now move into the
shed services cluster it's long-running
very important distinction here is that
Hadoop security becomes an important
aspect there's not a lot of point doing
authorization if you're not
authenticating the users so data sits in
GCS connect as many clusters as you want
spin up new clusters they'll have your
their policies available they'll have
the metadata available although
optimizes performance optimizations
which come with the metadata will be
available on
cluster and yeah okay so just just a
recap of the shared services this is
essentially what your system will end up
looking like there's gonna be one
long-running shared services cluster on
to which you're going to attach it's
it's plugged in with your LDAP it's
plugged in with Kerberos you can attach
as many ephemeral clusters as you want
to launch jobs or you can have
long-running clusters utilizing the same
metadata same policies long-running
cluster this is this is completely up to
the way organizations want to structure
their systems an example of a
long-running cluster would be in
n.l.a.p cluster which is serving
dashboards you don't necessarily want to
spin that down because it's serving our
dashboard so you just attach the same
coaster have your policy enforcement
have your metadata all of that manage
like this now this is where you really
get the agility of the cloud because one
you get capacity on the morn so if you
if on Prem for instance you've run out
of capacity Union on your Hadoop
deployment it takes a long time to get
new servers in place a lot of
organizations don't even want to get new
servers you were just provision a few
more instances on Google on Google cloud
and you have new capacity the other big
advantage here is you can leave your
existing workflow is running on you may
have pipelines already in place some
stable workflows or strong order said
you but you want to try out newer
versions of software you may have
sparked 2.3 or a new version of hi a new
version of SPARC you can just launch a
separate cluster which will attach again
to the same shared services cluster play
with it once you're happy with it you
will migrate it over to the you migrate
your production environment over to this
and of course similarly you can set up
next instances against the same
another paradigm is lift and shape for
data and GCS this is this is a very
feasible option some things to keep in
mind there's very few HDFS notes so in
theory it's easier to scale the other
thing to keep in mind over here is if
it's multi-tenant a single long-running
job can prevent scaling of the cluster
because there's in
major data which cannot be lost
otherwise a job will have to end up
reeling stages okay so this this talks
about the cluster shapes in respective
whether the shapes of this cluster a
femoral cluster long-running clusters
there's master nodes there are nodes
withdrawn temporarily HDFS as well as SS
compute and then there are compute only
nodes depending on the kind of
performance you want for your workloads
you would run all of these on non
preemptable VMs and to save cost you can
always run the computer only nodes on
additional preemptable VMs Hadoop knows
how to recover jobs in case no one's
going away and it will take care of all
of this for you so this this talks about
how the various Google components Google
Cloud components which are used HTTP hdf
will run on Google compute engine
ingests you bring your data into GCS you
write your data out to GCS the shared
services cluster you use cloud SQL for
Ranger and the meta store and the shared
services cluster again runs on Google
compute engine logging and monitoring
can be integrated into the shared
services cluster and part of it part of
the logging and monitoring would go in
over here where we have metrics wire and
body the other parts system system logs
could go into google logging Google
Cloud logging infrastructure alright so
covering some recommendations which are
very specific to Google cloud so
something to keep in mind is that this
performance scales with the size of the
disk up to a certain point so size it is
accordingly
also very important it is attached this
so Google Offers localizer stays and a
couple of attach this either spindles or
SSDs but attach this count towards
network traffic in fact they count
towards depending on the type of attach
this they count towards their a line of
8 3 X of the actual data being written
or 6x depending on whether it's so
original so that's something to be aware
of and this will compete with the actual
jobs running on
cluster shuffle data is okay so shuffle
data is essentially data which is
transferred between tasks during a
rolling job this is this is data which
if it's lost it doesn't matter because
again Hadoop knows we're so dope wrong
times know how to regenerate this data
if this data is small enough and for
best performance locally attached SSDs
is the way to go because you would not
be competing on the network bandwidth
this data is typically for a job
transferred in any case between nodes
and there's there's no real reason to
put it on to attach disks another
important point is to configure
independent disks because we don't know
is how to if a certain this goes bad it
would also just remove it and continue
running with the remaining disks Oh
temporary HDFS could be a few standard
persistent lists again its temporary you
don't really care too much all it's got
really is scratch directories
intermediate data things like that so
ever lately is a n.l.a.p provides
interactive performance with hive it
knows how to cache data it caches data
of the column level it doesn't cache
entire files it can either do this in
memory or on disk so given the
performance characteristics of the
various available local SSDs is the way
to go the one difference here is combine
these SSDs together because it will work
with only a single disk and combine them
together and configure a little ap to
use that as the cache and this can make
a pretty big performance of difference
when running because it's it's God the
data already fetched from cloud storage
it's nor the specific columns pre
fetched it's got metadata about the
information in the cache GCS is on it in
the same region that's pretty much the
most important thing over here you don't
necessarily need to run it you don't
want to be accessing data across regions
with GCS ok in terms of the network
configuration the bandwidth on a node is
linked to the number of course so that's
something to keep in mind while sizing
your nodes
the workers typically need higher
bandwidth so you would want more CPUs
over there we already covered this that
persistent discount towards the network
limit so configure things accordingly
Google offers a standard network here as
well as a premium tier for Hadoop or
shows most of the traffic is within the
cluster itself the standard network tier
is more than adequate and very important
is you use private IP is for your within
cluster traffic you do not want this
going to public IP is one it's an extra
hop to it also costs more in terms of
note sizing this this is not very
specific recommendations there's plenty
of information available and how to size
your notes this just talks about the
flexibility on Google's out so one thing
to keep in mind is that the note size
the cost for CPUs scales linearly so you
can size your notes accordingly there's
high mem knows as dedicated nodes if
required the other bit here is sustain
use and committed use discounts now the
committed use discount here is very
important because I think so how it
works in Google is your pay upfront for
CPU cores rather than instance types and
at a later point you can decide how to
use these course you can define
different instance types based on these
course master nodes especially in the
ephemeral clusters do not need to be the
biggest nodes in the cluster you're
owning fewer components it's absolutely
fine to size them smaller in terms of
cluster operations and maintenance and
ephemeral clusters are meant to be short
running you're typically not wrong
they won't be highly available you don't
need them to be upgradable what what
you're gonna do instead is if you need
an upgrade throw away your old floss or
spin up a new one on the other hand the
shares of this cluster is always on it's
all the ephemeral clusters and low
running costs is attached to this so you
want this to be highly available it has
to be upgradable it has to support
rolling updates
so yeah putting all this to
Cloudbreak 20.7 wishes Hortonworks which
is offered by Hortonworks support shared
services and lets you spend out these
environments HTTP 265 as well as 300
offers GCS connectivity and yeah that's
how you can play with us this point I'll
hand it over to John to talk about
fabric thank you Thanks it so I'm gonna
talk about cloud break today and this is
really about how do we pull everything
we've talked about today
cloud storage shared service
architecture with the ephemeral
workloads in the cloud but how do we
actually get to the cloud how do we get
these workloads and start performing big
data workloads on the platform and
that's really what cloud break does it's
all about provisioning workloads and
pulling in a lot of best practices of
prescriptive guidance into the way that
you provision these workloads on a
Google cloud platform so if we can
actually switch over to the demo
all right great the best way to really
talk about cloud break is to show it
live in action so I'm going to do a live
demo today fingers crossed here and kind
of walk through how you provision HTTP
and hdf workloads on to Google cloud
platform so the first thing I want to
point out here is I have a data Lake
cluster data like shared services
cluster provision just like Sid talked
about you know this is an architecture
where we're externalizing high meta
stored data
we're externalizing audit policies and
audit logging from the cluster itself
into the shared services architecture
and this is something that cloud breaks
supports so I've pre created a data like
shared services cluster you can see here
I have a couple external sources set up
I have my hive metaphor as well as my
Ranger database and audit logging
externalized from the clusters that I'm
gonna deploy so that's what I'm going to
do I'm gonna walk through creating a new
cluster and show you how easy it is to
deploy HTTP on a Google cloud platform
as well as attach that to a shared
services architecture so quite simply
I'll click
create cluster up here and I could
choose the data link that I want to
attach it to to get all those shared
services as I spin up these workloads
on-demand so I'll choose my data Lake
cluster 3 and my credentials so these
are credentials that I preset up in
Google cloud platform this is what
allows me to instantiate instances on
GCP as well as get HTTP 2.0 GCB so let's
give this a name we'll call it demo 3
choose my particular region here I'm
going to stick with the US East one the
platform I want to deploy whether that's
HTTP 2.6 whether that's 3.0 or hdf as
well so let's choose a data science
workload right out-of-the-box cloud
break includes several blueprints so if
you're familiar with in Bari blueprints
you'll be familiar with cloud break
blueprints and this is such a lets you
define the components services and
configurations of those components that
are going to be deployed in your HTTP
cluster so you can see we have three
here one for data science at DW workload
and ETL workloads as well with the
common components that would get
deployed for those workloads so let's go
ahead and choose data science we'll
click Next I'm actually going to get it
to the advanced UI now that I think
about it we have a basic and advanced UI
the basic UI is really good to get you
up and running very quickly the advanced
UI is if you're going to use the UI is
going to be what most enterprises would
do to get all the customizations that
they want set up a state provision
workloads so my image settings here I'm
going to use the base image settings
that we though we ship you can actually
create your own custom images so if you
have your own corporate enterprise
standards for images for some of the
Linux distributions that we support you
can certainly build those images and
deploy your corporate standard images
gold standards I'm going to use the
out-of-the-box images we have Hardware
in storage so this is where I can make
some adjustments to my hosts groups we
have a master node as you can see at the
far right this is going to be my Bari
server as well and we have worker nodes
and compute nodes host groups and I can
come in here and adjust any of the sizes
for the route volumes the number of
instances that I'm going to deploy
for compute notes here let's say we add
a add an instance here and deploy one
instance next and we've heard a lot
about cloud storage today that's
integrated with cloud break and
obviously HTTP to do some cloud storage
here I'm going to have to put in my
service account and let's put in my base
storage location and then we can attach
this to the hive warehouse using Google
Cloud storage
so cluster extensions again we give you
very prescriptive guidance and cloud
break on how to get these workloads up
and running but we understand again just
like custom images there's
customizations that you're probably
going to need to make so we have this
concept of recipes here this allows you
to run shell scripts and you can
determine at what point during the
cluster installation that these scripts
are going to run like I said premium
barri being installed is it posting
barri being installed is it actually a
recipe that runs when you terminate the
cluster and remove it as you would a
ephemeral workloads when there's no
longer a need for it but again these
recipes allow you to run shell scripts
and and example of that would be like if
you needed to join your host to an
active directory domain so you do all
the work for that upfront premium barri
install and then when you terminate the
cluster there's probably some Active
Directory cleanup work that you need to
do and you could have a recipe run at
that point all right let's go next and
talk about external sources and this is
a new capability we launched in cloud
break 2.7 is the notion of dynamic
blueprints so very likely instead of the
need to create one-off blueprints for
several different configurations but you
need you can have a single blueprint and
inject settings into that blueprint so
you can do things like one-time
configurations common would be if you
want to connect these to an LDAP
directory and do things like single
sign-on I have a LDAP directory set up
here in Active Directory
you can configure this to connect to
external databases these are probably
one time can
in settings that you want to set up and
just be able to easily select this next
now gateway configuration talked a
little bit about Knox we have the
ability to provision with cloud break
and wrap your clusters with an Apache
Knox powered secure gateway this is
great for limiting surface area of ports
that are exposed to the public internet
and really securing those services that
you want to publish for your your
cluster so we can do that right here
very prescriptive gun so we can wrap
that then we get to the network
configuration we can select existing
networks and subnets we want to attach
to we need to make sure in this case
because we're attaching to a data link
services closer and whatever selected
network and subnet you have defined can
communicate with the shared services
cluster as well you can come in here and
edit the security groups you can create
a new security group edit your existing
security groups we intelligently know
what services you want to deploy so
we're exposing the correct ports need
for that like 9 4 4 322 a 9 4 4 3 4
cloud break communication with the
cluster as an 8 4 4 3 and port 22 for
SSH as well and some last security
configurations they need to do give mine
Bari admin a password and put in my SSH
key so I can shell into the boxes now we
do support Kerberos as well
you can enable Kerberos if you want to
do that there are some prerequisite
checks that you need to kind of go
through to make sure that that's setup
for your environment correctly if you're
just doing some testing and getting up
with cloud break really quick to see how
easy it is to spin up workloads or try
some workloads on your own you can use a
test KDC we use an MIT KDC but again
this is only suitable for a test
environment not suitable for production
you should bring your own KDC and then
very simply create cluster
can see my new cluster being created
here depending upon how many nodes
you're deploying and whatnot usually
takes about 20 minutes here to get
through a complete cluster deployment
instantiate all the VN instances as well
as duty and Barney install and then add
all the nodes to the cluster as well
once done your cluster is going to look
similar to this one that I've already
created and attached to my daily you can
see here here's the gateway
configuration with all the endpoints for
all the services that I published
through Apache Docs I can see all my
external sources that are attached as
well as the cloud storage that I have
attached to this particular cluster one
popular feature for our customers is
auto scaling so once they get on the
cloud and I'm working with ephemeral
workloads I can actually resize this
workload and add additional compute
nodes I can add additional workload
worker nodes manually but auto scaling
is a great advanced feature here that we
have that allows you to scale up and
down based on different events that
happen so for example here we have
alerts and that's the basic four from
which you're going to create policies
that are going to happen here and alerts
can be time-based they're based on cron
expression so in particular times during
the day if you want to you know grow the
workload that you have the provision on
the cloud or you need to shrink it let's
say it's a batch job or something that
runs runs at night and you need to scale
up for that you can certainly do that
based on time you can also do that based
on any and barri metrics as well so
based on what you're seeing going on
that cluster if you need to you know if
you need to grow or contract and whatnot
and take advantage of the elasticity in
the cloud you can certainly do that and
then from the auto scaling policies
perspective again you can add nodes you
can remove nodes you can also set the
number of nodes to a particular number
of nodes that you want and then you
define which host group that this this
policy applies to all right great so
that's it for the demonstration just one
thing I want to mention real quick and
then we'll kind of go to the questions
we get some time for questions we do
have a booth it's on the third
or if you're coming from the escalators
it's all the way straight back it's
facing the stairs so come check us out
at the booth we can do demos for you
talk about any of the products that we
have then answer any questions that you
got so thank you very much for coming
[Music]